[Music]
hello everyone Perry here with another
exclusive Collider interview at San
Diego comic-con with some of the cast of
Stumptown if you enjoy this conversation
stay tuned for another one because we're
gonna have more of the cast right here
on the couch but right now thank you
guys so much for your time today
congratulations on that trailer I really
did enjoy just like the style and vibe
of that and I can't wait to see the
first episode Chloe I wanted to start
with you on this one because you have
tons of TV experience but this is I
believe your first time headlining a
show so low so did that come with any
added pressure for you yeah that's very
much ah yes it's very I don't know why
I'm in this industry because I don't
like seeing pictures of myself I don't
like taking pictures of myself but here
I am I think I was so specific to this
project I was so drawn to this character
this character of Dex on our show she's
so multi-layered and just fascinating
and I like kind of a mess of a human
being but also so honorable and really
is is noble and everything she tries to
do she always has the best intentions
but never quite never quite makes it
work have you taken a photo of yourself
in front of that gigantic building right
about there I am ignoring it it doesn't
exist in my mind I looked at it and I
filed it away and it doesn't exist
anymore that's fair I still find it very
extremely weird I mean it'll never be
that's not normal that's not normal
but I'm happy that they're promoting our
show that is something you it's
something to be very proud of for all
three of you now I'm curious when you
approach a project like this do you
prioritize reading the source material
first or would you rather stick to the
script I'm not sure how much the show
actually does stick to what happens in
the graphic novel I when I first read
the script I immediately asked to read
the graphic novels and I found it really
helpful just in terms of trying to
establish a tone the city of Portland
which I wasn't that familiar with and
also the characters I mean it's all
there in the graphic novel but I think
we will take
that and kind of elevated on to
television and explore the world a
little bit more for some reason I was
very surprised the two you hadn't worked
together before there's something about
your comedic sensibilities that I yeah
oh yeah they just cared so well so can
you tell me a little bit about sparking
that that history and also that
chemistry between those two characters
barking we haven't worked together but
we've worked with a lot of the same
people right Tom Cruise dropped it Tom
Cruise we we actually we I feel like
that first time we actually had a
conversation was in what Tom calls the
pain cave which is his his roaming Jim
that goes with him everywhere and Jake
was in the midst of training and I was
there doing reshoots so um shout out to
Tom Cruise's what is the worst thing
you've ever experienced in the pain cave
do you remember what it with those those
exercises recall where you had to
achieve like 500 push-ups 500 squats and
but every but it was like a team thing
it was called like a like a relay I
can't remember the word they use that
term oh yeah that sounds extremely
you've never looked better and felt
better in your life Michael and curious
for you was it kind of a step away going
from almost human to this it's a
completely different type of cop
character there but is there anything
about Dorian that kind of helped you out
here no no I think you know Dorian
always wanted to I think Dorian sought
out humanity which was his tragic flaw
he was he was AI but he really wanted to
attain humanity he couldn't get it
I think Hoffman I think and we'll find
out more as we keep going but I think
Hoffman is somewhat turned off by
humanity um a little bit you know kind
of annoyed with where things are in
in life but at the same time finds
almost a kindred spirit in in index can
you guys describe the tone of the show
at all cuz it's like in the graphic
novel I love her sass and her comedic
sensibilities but it also feels very
dangerous to me so are we gonna say that
it is it is a hard it's hard to describe
to be honest I mean I've been calling it
like an action drama D like it is it is
all three themes kind of wrapped up into
one it's very funny we have an amazing
supporting cast and and also we're
basing this in Portland which is just
full of unique looking people unique
characters so it's gonna be you know
we're really trying to do something
that's new and different yes I am a PI
and there are police officers abound but
it is gonna be a character-driven show
and it is gonna be like we hope unlike
anything that has been I think it's a
show that would make a lot of sense when
it was pitched to me on like a streaming
network and I think it's really bold and
exciting that it's on ABC so I think
that's gonna be the kind of bridge that
I'm excited to see how we do it because
I think if this we were announcing this
and we were on Netflix Stumptown based
off those graphic novels would make a
lot of sense and I think we're gonna try
to keep it as interesting as it could be
on streaming on network and I've been
able to answer my own tone question very
easily had it been on Netflix versus the
pitch that I've gotten that I believe
everybody's gotten is we're not going to
cut any corners and we are going to push
it as much as we can as if it were on
anywhere else so at this point we have
the trailer out there and the scene
that's heavily in the trailer is that
car scene so just to give everybody a
little behind-the-scenes of what
actually happened in there cuz I imagine
shooting something like that is super
chaotic is there anything about nailing
a sequence like that that made you think
like it's crazy that I'm doing this I
mean how so much of that sequence and
really any action sequences in the
editing you know you're doing it over
and over again and you're like okay we
can use that hit from that take we can
use that you know me from that take and
so you just end up doing it so many
times and and to the credit of the other
actors in this scene we're talking about
a scene where there's two guys in the
front
I'm in the back and I kind of come out
of the trunk he had to be hit with that
fake last bottle like so many times and
it was really on them to sell the
violence of it and they really threw
themselves into it so you know it's like
a day where you're like I'm gonna be
sore tomorrow and it really comes alive
when it's all edited it plays very well
I'm a big fan of trailers that let a
scene breathe yes you jump in - yes the
show a very effective start to the case
I'm very excited for you guys thank you
so much for your time guys Stumptown on
ABC it's coming your way super suit
September 25th that's the day we better
get to work
check it out guys also if you enjoyed
this interview stay tuned because you're
gonna get an end card with a link to a
whole nother conversation about
Stumptown thanks for watching this video
like and share and we'll see you soon
with more Comic Con coverage